this is how this is all the things you
need that the actual phrasing of this
question is a little more arm too little
more wedding but the lovely thing about
it is with some practice we can wrap
their heads are a rough enough around
this notation but this tells you
everything ok what we have is
acceleration as a function of
displacement like that this is no longer
you might remember I've yesterday we're
looking at that weight on the spring
right and it was going up and down and
we did a simple model of it when we
imagine the spherical cow hasn't worked
with it not Daphne at all it just got up
and down up down so we could take
advantage as we answered that question
we could take advantage of all the
features of a simple harmonic motion
that was kind of nice you're not in
Kansas anymore ok you can't do any
simple hug least most of stuff with this
not at all that you've got some initial
conditions and what we're asking for is
two things number one can we get me
squared as a function of displacement
can we get displacement as a function of
time and then on the base of that can we
briefly describe the motion ok so
there's the cell how are we going to
begin yes then I want you to remember
can you quote it for me there were
actually don't wait let's do all of them
so there are five different ways that we
know to write acceleration that's the
first one second be learned i can say
acceleration by definition is the change
in velocity over time ok so that's a
good one but of course because we itself
is a derivative this is the second
derivative of displacement with respect
to time with the Texas i okay and then
we got these last two yesterday we had
to do some are some algebraic and some
calculus backflips we did chain rule a
couple of times the first one was
acceleration not in terms of
displacement but acceleration in terms
of velocity do you remember that one
what was it it started with v DV on the
air now we're not going to use that one
in this particular example but we are
going to use the next one which was a
few steps underneath we got to TX
okay yep so you could write this a
couple of different ways I tend to write
this heart B squared up here it does
really legitimate doesn't matter and my
DX there but you could write D on DX or
half a square ok now we're going to use
this one it's kind of a giveaway that
we're going to use this for two reasons
series number one kind of a look at the
way question is phrased they want to be
sweat so look use the one with ree
square okay there's another clue what's
the other clue that tells you that's the
one who use exhalation is a function
displacement right when you have a look
at each of these expressions this is in
terms of velocity and this is in terms
of displacement you see what's going on
ok so I don't really have any way to
access is because I don't have any visa
great with respect to all those kind of
things okay so you will encounter
questions where you'll see X double dot
and there will be veins in that equation
and that's your signal that you should
use this one but we're not there yet
okay so if that's the form of
acceleration we're going to use let's
just use that as a substitution router
pop up top pi x double dot instead of
that I'm gonna write this derivative
okay so i can quote that excellent what
do I do with this okay so i'm going to
integrate both sides read this chapter X
that's going to give me half v square on
the left hand side and on the right hand
side so there's execute that's just the
preview and of course that comes along
for the ride however because I'm about
to double this thing and get to be
squared by the path P Square I just got
it for the safety convenience call this
ah see right and see is a real number
some constant pain up there okay
multiply through
I've got an expression for V squared but
I'm a concert here of it what do i do to
get rid of this costume very good i have
conditions right they happen to be
initially so I'm going to go these two
here these two are happening at the same
time so i can substitute them in here
right so i can say when a teak was one
vit it cause [ __ ] drew two so what does
this next slide look like this is going
to be 2 times 1 i'll just write that
bracket citizen tip what what plus my
constant equals to do so c is equal to
ok that's kind of convenient so i've got
the spin is 2x kids excellent looks good
so I now have answered pie that's going
to get progress but now I have to get to
this expression over here okay now I
want you to pause for a moment last time
we didn't worry we're over with the
spring we didn't worry about time at all
really we never had to bring it in okay
but here they specifically asking you to
get back to a function of time okay now
how are you going to do this what kind
of time formation do you have given to
you in the question you have you have a
single word initially right which tells
you t equals 0 yes so in order to use
that I've got to somehow like sort of
muck about with this and manipulated
such that I get teased in there where
are the teeth yet again want Mexicans
DX you say are you saying which one
which one you take this this one here
this one here okay so I want to bring a
two year right a dt is a good way to do
it but in order to use this I have to
have my acceleration function right so i
can say that's equal to divvy up dt but
this is no use this is not with respect
to time right so this is not going to be
useful to me okay so I Dramat this one
here this with me okay so i could say
that but it's still we just went to tire
and that's not with respect to time okay
so I'm kind of still out in the wash
right let me give you a bit of a tip
give you a bit or two we're currently
considering going back to acceleration
right we wanted to get to displacement
from acceleration to displacement how
many steps are there between is to write
there's displacement velocity
acceleration now we don't have a
velocity function yet but I almost do
right so it doesn't it make more sense
like this is closer to a displacement
function that this is in any way I've
already done some integration here so
this is going to be my launching point
okay